[Music]
hello everybody
welcome to Google cloud next we are
super pumped to have all of you here
today and even more excited to tell you
a little bit about what it's like to be
a Googler which I'll tell you going back
a few years how many of you have seen
the movie the internship Owen Wilson
yeah that's totally what I pictured life
at Google being like and yes there are
some truths to that movie but we're
gonna learn a little bit more about what
it's like to work at Google what the
week in the life of a Googler is what
it's like to be a software developer and
product manager at Google and we've got
some incredible panelists who will be
sharing a little bit more about the in
depths of what it's like to be at Google
to kick things off I'll introduce myself
my name is Kristen Copeland I'm staffing
lead here at Google so part of our
people operations organization and we
are unfortunately are missing one of our
panelists you couldn't make it today but
I will kick it over to our wonderful
very intelligent panelists to introduce
themselves and tell you just a little
bit about their name what they currently
do here at Google and their role so
watch me over to you thank you i'm
lakshmi Sherma i'm director of product
management for networking so with my
team you know product managers and
working with my engineering team I I try
to kind of support the awesomeness of
high performance low latency network
that a lot of our Google services most
of our Google services and cloud
services are built upon everybody I'm
Tara Hernandez I'm an engineering
manager in Google cloud division my team
specifically works on developer tools
and container images so if you do things
with kubernetes you're probably using
our stuff at some way but don't complain
I'm the manager hi my name is Jimmy I
work for Google clouds video
intelligence
well I focus on video if you use any of
our AI API is that's probably related to
my team thank you
hi everyone I'm Marissa ciao I'm a
software engineer on a team working on
building video conferencing tools
specifically at Google although we
partner very closely with our friends in
hangouts meet part of G suite to bring
all the cool technologies you awesome ok
so first things first let's just kind of
hit the baseline here and I'd love to
hear a little bit from each of you about
what does the weak and the life of a
Googler look like specifically in your
role so as an engineering manager as a
software developer and as a product
manager so taro why don't you kick
things off for us meetings in fact my
team was really excited because I made
them go to less meetings and they were
it was practically tears of relief the
company the size of Google and with the
scope that we have just even within the
cloud space trying to get coordinated
make sure that we're moving towards a
common goal is very challenging but it's
also pretty exciting too I'm used to a
small company my last company had 224
employees a little has been a different
experience for me to say the least I can
absolutely imagine and and can relate
I'm sure many of you can as well
Jimmy tell us a little bit about what a
typical week looks like for you as a
Googler sue me as a software engineer
because it's already into Korea mostly
coding since the 80s I'll say 80% coding
the rest is just meetings but we're
really selling it here are we but the
meetings do help because that's how you
design we'd like to design as a team
which is pretty good to get that team
working meetings get the design down you
come up with an idea share with your
teammates then after that you get to
implement and everyone goes your way and
we kind of just work together so mostly
it's coding but there's a lot of
teamwork involved in that
yeah very similar to Jimmy software
development at Google is mostly coding I
like to tell people that you know most
of my time is coding and the rest of the
time I'm trying I'm sitting in meetings
deciding what to code that is that is my
week awesome and Lakshmi I know your
rules a little bit different but are you
in meetings all day too
so I'll just give an example of like you
know how my first day here at Google was
so I joined January 8th last year I was
in Google training I came to meet my
team and my peers so I came to the PM
area and then it was before 5:00 p.m.
and there was nobody out there so and
then I was told already hey most of the
p.m. they're always talking to customers
internal-external they must be in some
other building talking to some kind of
customer all stakeholders and I went in
and there was nobody so so yeah meetings
but it's just that you're always talking
to somebody who is that's the kind of
life of a product manager you are
talking to customers and those customers
are internal customers like you know or
our engineering stakeholders marketing
people sales people so we are always
talking to a lot of people learning and
then trying to build kind of you know
products that that our customers really
really can use yeah tell us a little bit
more about the the relationships with
customers how you interact with them and
sort of just like how that partnership
looks I've been a various big and small
company so one thing which I would say
like you know one advantage of being at
Google and I would be honest there's a
blessing I would say being Google and
having this company done so much of
amazing work and infrastructure I work
in infrastructure team it's it's always
that brand and the performance and the
quality that we have it is actually easy
to go and talk to customers they want to
listen to you primarily because like you
know we are so much engineering focus so
the typical day is like you know we work
very closely with engineering team like
product management team here is a two in
a box like we work with engineering and
we have like you know we say out outside
in as well as in word focus innovation
so we here talk to customers all the
time like since morning I've been
talking to partners and customers we
learn from them we build for them and
then we also have our
innovation coming from you know billions
of users who have been using our
services so it's like you know a
continuous learning continuous in
continuous innovation and we keep giving
to each other throughout the world to
our customers as well as to our own
services that's awesome um what about
for the rest of you I'd love to hear a
little bit more about on your day to day
talk to me about how you're working with
open source or how you're working with
internal consumers or projects that are
maybe related but upstream go ahead take
it off tie right go
so I've done engineering infrastructure
for 25 something years I was involved in
open source as far back as Mozilla so
it's something that's super important to
me and being able to work at a company
like Google where all the things that my
team works on are all open source based
is pretty awesome
Marissa why don't you tell us a little
bit about what is your favorite thing
about being a developer at Google it's a
vivid cliche there are a lot of things I
really enjoy about being a developer and
I mean right off the bat my my teammates
that I have are just really incredible
you know I came to Google basically
fresh out of college and so I was moving
from an environment where coding was
very theoretical right the problems that
we had were all theoretical in nature
okay so this is what it might look like
to deal with concurrency problems you
know but then when you come to Google
you are suddenly thrown into this
environment where you're not only forced
to see like how these how the
theoretical principles play out in
practice but also you're challenged by
so many different factors that you don't
really think about when you're in the
vacuum of university so for example our
video conferencing fleet is all
throughout the world so we deal with a
lot of problems around for example time
zone issues or problems of you know
different
different hardware available in
different in different countries all of
the like problems of scale as well if we
for example if one percent of our of our
videoconferencing fleet goes down that's
hundreds of rooms that can't be can't be
managed or can't be used at all by
Googlers in a certain office or around
the world so thinking about how the like
the theories of university days can are
put into practice I guess and tested in
many different ways in the in the daily
developer workflow has been very it's
been it's been such a growing experience
for me as a developer to see how that
plays out to think about scale from the
beginning to think about the user from
the start yeah that's amazing
and what about from the product
management side Lakshmi tell us a little
bit more about what your favorite thing
about being a PM at Google is so we you
know we say that p.m. at Google product
management at Google is the CEO of their
product and in it it we truly believe in
that sense like you are a CEO of a
product and all that startup that you
run and then you run with your CEOs and
you know other architects of the company
which are all your engineering leaders
so it's this definition I have not have
been a leader in many companies and
weenus places it is not practice to that
extent and to that scale and impact and
at least in places where I have been so
it's it's just awesome that you can just
think of an idea then you just meet an
engineering leader like me you know just
sitting next to you and then say how
about we work together on this then you
go and find a customer you put or you go
and find your you know open-source
partners and if it works out but what
works out fault you know we always think
like global scales so nothing starts
regionally for us we always start that
well it affect will this problem we
solve for everybody around the world and
then if it does we just go and ask for
more people we put a business case
together and sometimes that idea does
not exist that product never existed
it's
truly as simple as that I've been here
15 months and there are so many new
things I've done in all kinds of aspects
partnerships business step you name it
and then you just find the right people
and there are amazing sort of people so
it's just rocking awesome to be I'm not
just doing a sales pitch I truly mean it
so it's really really wonderful to be
yeah incredible opportunities to make an
impact I think one of my favorite
stories I was asking a Googler you know
kind of what's what's here what's your
Google moment and he shares with me that
he was you know a noogler a new Googler
as we call it and he's working on this
like business critical project and it's
essentially you know when you do a
Google search and the little cards show
up to like quickly give you your your
snapshot of your answer he was working
on that and a few months after they
launched they got in the team got a
random email forwarded to them from a
woman in India who noted that she was
able to quickly do a quick search on
some of her symptoms that she was having
quickly diagnosed herself went in and
and advocated for herself to get the
right care and ended up saving both her
life and she was pregnant and her baby's
life so I think it's just incredible
these like crazy ways that we can you
know make just an impact with something
that feels like it may not too many of
you have sort of a Google moment or
something that's really just helped you
to to feel connected to Google and just
love the magic moments that we have here
I know this one wasn't on the script I'm
throwing it at you a little bit I have
one when I was noogler you know you
spend three days down in the main campus
learning about Google and learning the
tools and etc but one of the things I
did not know when I got to Google was
this cool story out of the Arab Spring
where you know you have all of these
activists trying to app
and support democracy in their countries
and in many cases you have these very
repressive governments trying to shut
down the internet to prevent them from
communicating with each other and one of
the things that came out is that people
were spray-painting Google's DNS server
address which is eight eight eight eight
on walls of buildings so that they could
keep their Twitter feeds going and
various other social media and having
not known that I was like wow okay I
work at a cool company that was that was
pretty awesome to me and to consider I
had like sort of said I'd never work at
Google because Google is that stupid
company that makes you makes you
calculate how many golf balls are in a
school bus or something as part of your
interview process which I can certainly
no longer do that you know to be able to
be part of an organization that has had
that much of a significant positive
impact in the world in such a meaningful
way it's it's hard to it's kind of hard
to top that in my mind I love it except
I'm sure you're gonna top that right not
quite but that is quite hard but what
when I realized this is where I was
working on a new project where it's a
new API we have an idea we implementing
it and everyone's excited about it and
we want to launch it so we were like I
was talking to one of my senior
engineers and a team and I'm like yeah
right now the servers are pretty good
they're pretty stable or I can guarantee
you like 99% of the time they're gonna
be up and he's like no it's not enough
but what do you mean 99% of the time
he's not enough like yeah we need 99.99%
of the time it's like a that 1% can
bring down a lot of can affect a lot of
users in it in one second and then he
went ahead and give me this equation and
I calculated how much how many uses we
have you know just our team and how much
like 10 minutes of one server going down
could affect the ultimate product like
that number just blew my mind I was like
okay yeah this is big scale absolutely
all right so we talked a little bit
about what some of your favorite things
about being a developer or a product
manager or working at Google are let's
here
more about that that real talk like peek
under the 10:00 what are your least
favorite things can I say the good one
first oh of course
okay I'm infrastructure so I only talk
infrastructure language and if you had
seen the keynote this morning and so to
me one of the most powerful thing was
like imagining putting a fiber under the
ocean and like instead of just you know
I've always been in companies which will
do software innovation hardware
innovation ASIC make all kinds of
innovation but it means okay so we have
a very high latency between Australia
and Singapore so how do we fix it we did
all the wonderful things let's just put
a fiber and then we reduce the latency
oh my god the moments like that are I
think just you have to every single
innovation out there and then you do the
something like the company of a Google
scale can offer to the world
I think that's those are my aha moments
top notch absolutely all right back to
the real talk
so one of my least favorite things
actually relates to what relates to my
favorite moment as well which is kind of
crazy but in that the same kind of
example that I just showed I just told
you guys
is it because Google is such a big
company sometimes it hinders the speed
that you want to do things that so I'd
say you're working on a project and you
have everything done if you're in a
smaller company you could get it out
pretty fast and kind of iterate faster
but sometimes because Google is still a
very big company you really need to they
really they to everyone is to be
confident and like the quality has to be
the highest quality possible so it does
take a little bit longer time which as a
developer you just want to get it I want
people to be able to help be helped by
what I've just done and it just really
hurts kind of to wait like another
quarter and just slowly go to the
reviews and everything until it's ready
to launch so yeah that's my kind of
yeah a lot of trade-offs when you're
worried about scale and high impact you
got to also make sure that it's not
adversely impacting folks which means
things can move a little slower I get
that okay Marisa yeah I think related to
Jimmy's point about the scaler which
Google has grown mister I mentioned
earlier Google's not a very small
company anymore it is a very large
company across you know all over the
world and offices all over the world and
so my team does collaborate with teams
that are located in the different time
zones and so part of my so part of the
frustration with that is the company is
so large that sometimes it can be very
difficult to know like what other parts
of the company are doing so it's it's
not at all unusual for for for me to
look first learn of sort of some Google
products when they show up in TechCrunch
and it's just it's just one of the facts
of being a large company but I think
that's that's something I've actually
taken a bit to heart because I work on a
G suite product where I work on meetings
I work on trying to make that
collaboration that connection better I
work on trying to make that more
seamless more frictionless and so I
think that that kind of gripe with with
how large the company is is something
that fuels me as well I love it Sahra
anything you'd like to share should we
move on all right all right I'm gonna
get in trouble one of my favorite thing
is it because it's meetings you hate
meetings the most one of my favorite
questions to ask folks is you know when
you're working at Google there's so many
other companies that you could choose
from what brought you to Google and
what's kept you here
tarah take it away all right I actually
like I said I had never plan on working
for Google not just because of the
interview questions but just because I
like small companies the ability to have
impact at a small company is just so
much to your point it's just so much
easier
but I met some amazing women at meetups
and cloud events and one in particular
woman named melody McPhee so another one
Diane Greene Alyssa Greene there's just
all of these amazing women and I was
like wow here's a company that has this
sort of fulcrum of people that I could
really learn from and have an
opportunity to work with and I thought
all right well okay maybe I hate big
companies but this is too good an
opportunity to pass up
plus they let me work in the San
Francisco office so that was an added
benefit I like it so for me you don't
know my background I was born in
Tanzania so growing up in kind of third
world country it was quite a change of
scenery for me to come to the United
States and through my time in college I
realized that I want to dedicate my life
to show like real problems that affect
people and I didn't really care about
how many users you rack up for all these
different companies we're talking about
but at Google I the really drew me to
Google was the problem they're trying to
solve first their effect they try to
affect the whole world so not just the
United States or the first world they
turn affect everywhere and their
problems are actually affecting people
and enabling people to do more with
their lives and enjoy their time more so
it's problems I really cared about so
that's what drew me into Google and what
kept me at Google to be honest I think
it's the food there's food in the fridge
food is gotta be up there like that is
one of my favorite things every time I
think of living in my Oh but okay I'm
just never mind right we're very spoiled
I'm sure most of you have heard about
the food but I can say that it's one of
those things I think I saw something on
and we can mean the other day that was a
making fun of Googlers who were talking
about like I'd rather work in the San
Francisco office because they have the
oat milk instead of almond milk and
that's a little
painting the picture of how spoiled we
can be a little bit New York office has
steak okay while I'm moving in you're
clearly alright tell me about hey what
are a little bit more about what brought
you sorry I'm gonna move on to watch me
because you started that one for us
clearly I'm just crushing it right now
y'all Lakshmi tell me what brought you
to Google and what's kept you here I
think like almost everybody said that
the so I like the impact the scale of
the impact that anybody can make any
single person can make so and I mean
networking networking infrastructure
anything everything is connected and
secured through some kind of networking
right all the way from the device to
on-prem device to a data center to cloud
so so and this is a company which has
built it over years and securely and
phenomenally well and and I think it was
a perfect timing because we are not
number one yet and cloud game so I had
huge scope to kind of you know
participate in and at the scale that I
was looking at there is no other place
and I could have thought about where I
could have an impact where there was so
much to do at the scale that they had
already done so so you know and whatever
what is keeping me adjust that even
after 15 months every day I feel like my
new I'm a noogler there is so much to do
so so that's what it's like my my
promise to myself that I will make I
will be able to make an impact and will
be able to work with really smart brains
some every single day I meet somebody oh
my god oh this person wrote the book oh
my god this person did so it's just
every day those moments and then
learning from them and being humble
that's keeping me here that's amazing so
speaking of the smart people that you
come in contact what one more thing the
thing excuse me at Google we can bring
dogs to the office
bring dogs to the office the dogs
puppies in the office is literally one
of my favorite things about Google I
can't even handle the cuteness somedays
two of my co-workers have like the
cutest puppies I've ever seen and I'm so
sorry to get on this tangent but yes
dogs in the office is amazing but you
did touch on something that I want to
dig a little deeper on the the point of
working with people who are just so
intelligent I give you my quick
experience so I was leading a meeting
and one of those meetings where like I
kind of felt like yeah I got this I'm
gonna nail this I'd you know went into
the meeting I was strong and confident
felt like I rocked the meeting and then
afterwards someone was like did you know
that that guy in the meeting with you he
like was a badass at Atari like he was
one of those people that like made huge
impact was like built all these
incredible games and like you just like
you know made sure that he knew exactly
what he needed to do and he's super
senior and then all of a sudden the next
time I'm meeting with him I'm sitting
there like oh this guy's so smart I'm
gonna look like an idiot in front of him
so it gave me a little bit of imposter
syndrome of what it's like to work with
these crazy intelligent amazing people
and I'd love to hear a little bit more
about how you if you experienced
impostor syndrome at Google or how you
deal with I think this is one of the
reason that I did not Google had been my
customer partner I've worked with you
know and many times in vendor but I
never wanted to work with Google one of
the reasons was that hey from outside it
looks like when there are so many small
people who have so many things in life
you know the impression that you feel
like if I am there one I'll be lost like
you know whether I'll be able to make an
impact and second is that oh would I get
the kind of respect that I get out of
the places I experience internally is
like just like you said so I'll do a
very quick example so I grew up in India
I did my masters in computer science
from India and there's a very common
book that a lot of Indians read all the
time like in masters which is around
computer architecture so the person one
of the authors of that book I have been
working with this person
ever since I joined last year just
recently another person who joined my
team again this person is Indian says Oh
watch me isn't he better halt like I
said yeah so say isn't he the weather
hall who wrote the book I'm like what
book so then I actually look at him I
said David did you write that book he
says yeah and I'm just going like oh my
god I mean the 13 months or I'm working
with this person every day and I I read
his book and almost every person at
least you know 18 years back in India
used to read that book so that's the
kind of humbleness and I can give names
and names like person who wrote ECP you
know wins like amazing person I got to
me that person with no air everybody
here is just here to solve problems for
people and that's a common thing that
keeps us all connected and that's all we
do I just get goose bumps and because I
am engineer at heart I'm a product
manager but meeting those people who are
so humble and then just it's just you
know so I've actually given talks on
impostor syndrome and I suffer from it
every day and the thing that I love
about at Google is that so does
everybody else it's something that gets
talked about a lot and you think about
I'm sure everybody's heard of the Google
20% projects and that's pretty widely
known like there was somebody who had a
20% project and invented Gmail right and
it just passed 15 years and has like 90
bazillion users and you think oh my god
I'm working at a company where someone
just thought of that as a side project
that's very intimidating but at the same
time to Lakshmi's point there's a
there's a lot of motivation around we
all have the capability and opportunity
to really do something meaningful for us
and for the company and morter to
jimmy's point to the world at large it's
it's very it's not often that you get to
work at a company that could have global
impact and so there's a sense of
responsibility that i think a lot of us
carry that you know maybe it's not the
official motto but every employee is you
know do good don't be evil don't take it
for granted all of those things that for
us as as Googlers
in the trenches working along it's like
we think about it all the time yeah
intent in some ways and a sense of sort
of technical ethics and and other types
of things are things that are just as
important as what type of you know crazy
technical innovation is gonna make us a
lot of money right that's not really
what we care about as much at least with
all of the people that I have met that's
not the case I'd love to hear a little
bit more about skills that you've
developed at Google because I have seen
some of these different courses we have
available to us and have benefited from
them I recently took a finance course
which is amazing because let's be real I
know nothing about how to invest so I'd
love to hear what's a skill that you've
developed here at Google whether or not
it's related to your court job or
something that you've you learned to be
a courses that we offer sure so I'll
list to one technical skill and then one
non technical skill technical skill is
so my team works on video conferencing
as I mentioned and a large part of that
is reliability so making sure that our
rooms are reliably working at any given
point in time so a huge part of my job
is looking at rooms that are broken
trying to diagnose why something is you
know why is why a room is suddenly went
offline and there was just so many
dimensions to that problem is it a
problem in the software is there problem
in the hardware is there problem in the
building is it you know any like there
are layers and layers of where where the
problem could happen so a lot of so I
would say one skill that I've developed
is learning to look at you know a
symptom and try to think about like what
are the causes that could affect that
that could make that happen where along
the chain could something go wrong the
non-technical skill is really fun I
learned I took an ASL class at at the
office they offer ASL classes and I I it
was something I'd always wanted to learn
and didn't really have a chance to learn
so when they offered to class I just
jumped at it and there's a lot of fun I
really enjoyed it
that's great so the skillet I learned
actually it's weird because I thought I
was the master of C++ I was like there's
nothing I can learn more about C++
that's that's what I learned
so at Google we have this thing where
after you joined to come the company you
can go through with the b2 reviews and
you have people who are very
knowledgeable in the language review
your code and give you pointers as to
what you do and my first readability
approval review that was the most
exciting moment I ever had because I
learned so much in that one review then
let's say a year in college because I
was gave me pointers in reasons and why
this is like you give the whole
rationale do it like this because of ABC
and you think about your life yes why
not think of that before and you go back
and it's every time I have those reviews
it's just amazing and you these people
work in the company and you can just
like ping them I'm like do you want to
have lunch no be like yeah let's get
once we have steak over here so you go
and talk to them and you learned so I
like I am a super sports nerd so I enjoy
you having lunch with these people and
the more I learned the more happy I am
so I don't think you're ever gonna be a
massive super plus that's what I learnt
as well so nice I love it I love it so
in our last minute or so we'll end on a
fun note I I'd love for each of you one
of you mentioned the great food at
Google I'd love to hear from each of you
wait what the best thing you've eaten at
Google is the best food you've eaten at
Google yeah
all right so - that's gonna be Japan
office it's been Tokyo they had the Hat
I don't know what the name of the food
is but it was just it's different from
here because you have it's sort of just
one meal is meals everywhere and you
just pick and choose and eat and I
remember eating the first time I was
there ate so much that I got sick but it
was so good it was like a Japanese
version of tapas okay yeah I can get on
board with that
Lakshmi what about you so I'm vegetarian
no and no egg no meat no seafood so so
one thing which I really love is that
the food here is super healthy and I I
do like healthy food so you have all
kinds of options but out of all the
offices I'll travel Google like
Singapore office they have like a seven
star buffet is and the view is so super
awesome so uh it's it's that's my
favorite place for vegetarian food all
right what about you
chocolate chip cookies at the San
Francisco office they have sea salt
I feel like my answer to this changes
every week but yes I just so and in the
New York office they have this one cafe
where they will plate everything very
nicely on like a huge plate so you see
this beautiful white plate and I'll have
like a perfect like I don't know
I'm blinking but like for example like
some sort of really fancy pasta with
like a pumpkin sauce on it with a
beautiful sprig of like green something
I don't yeah gold Leafs or something no
it's just so beautiful and you know I as
an as a millennial I have to say it's
very Instagram Abul is very aesthetic if
it's I G worthy I also have hidden bars
and peanut butter sandwiches
they just started it recently in
Sunnyvale office I love them you know a
simple staple who doesn't love that
fantastic all right well that wraps up
our panel today so let's give it up for
these amazing panelists guys thank you
all so much we hope you enjoyed learning
a little bit more about what it's like
in the life of a Googler
[Music]